there are perks of living in a town
whose football club is owned by a
hollywood a-lister
the people of wrexham are amongst the
first in the world
to lay eyes on ryan reynolds in his
latest action comedy
the star of the silver screen became a
co-owner of wrexham football club
in a bizarre and unexpected purchase
last year
he told us this is the role of a
lifetime
i'm excited to just be in the town
and experience all that the town has to
offer and
that there's such a rich history in
wrexham
and there's such a legacy of incredible
uh adoration and love
for this club and you know we kind of
feel like both the community and the
club are
really intertwined there's a real buzz
here for the football season to begin
and with it just days away this tired
and neglected stadium
now has motion picture money to bring it
back to life
what's really special uh with with rob
and ryan is their
their values in terms of you know not
only making sure the football club and
the culture around the club
and you know it is positive and
sustainable it's that wider
reach these are the start of the
non-league journey so when i first
started watching them
alex just lives around the corner a
season ticket holder for 14 years
she says fans and the town itself have
never been so excited
who would have thought ryan reynolds
will be wanting to come to little old
wrexham
in north wales so it makes people proud
to be from wrexham again and they put us
back on the map because i think that had
gone a little bit now it's like
we're getting a screen of his film and
he's going to be here in a week and it's
like
hold on this doesn't happen to us it's a
bit
yeah it's crazy this community is well
and truly riding the hollywood wave
and with the stars having such a
hands-on approach wrexham town
is certainly feeling the wider benefits
but most
importantly i wouldn't dare call it
soccer uh
uh i care about my well-being enough to
not call it soccer
whatever the canadian calls it wrexham
won't mind
this steely town packed with people full
of grit
is being met with a coating of hollywood
stardust
and it's hugely welcome ins man rasheed
sky news
wrexham